[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's mickey guyton kicking off super
bowl 56. yeah
the country star electrified the crowd
at schofie stadium on sunday belting out
a stunning performance of the national
anthem
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
mickey hid all the right notes with her
take on the star-spangled banner which
followed jenae aiko's performance of
america the beautiful
[Music]
and while some viewers put money on the
rams or bengals mickey's fans gambled
elsewhere there's bets going on what
color i'm wearing well congrats to
everyone who picked blue
i am
freaking
out oh my god heading into sunday's big
game mickey opened up to et about what
makes this honor so important it's just
so much i i still
again like literally two years ago this
was not even a possibility for me and
now i'm seeing the national anthem at
the super bowl like
it's wild okay so let's unpack a little
bit of this here how did this come
together was it something that's always
been on your list
well
i think everybody would love to perform
at the super bowl at some form or
another
i just never thought it was a
possibility for me so i always just
enjoyed watching the performances
watching the national anthem and i love
i sing the national anthem at my high
school i sing the national anthem at
every basketball game that we had
basically so
i know the song very well i just didn't
you know it was never a possibility what
does this performance mean to you though
knowing that this is actually happening
for you
you know i have been wanting to do music
for so long and to be able to stand on
the stage on this day
there's so much division in this country
and there's so much that is happening
that's hard and this this is a moment
that i get to
to to be that black girl from texas that
gets to stand on that stage and sing
back come on and hopefully i can really
unite country you know i'm gonna have a
choir behind me
and it's all the faces of america and
this is the america that i will be proud
to wave my
american flag emoji for
[Music]